we're gonna take a look at a little look
at debugging and kind of just the state
of debugging with nodejs and to give you
a little bit of context I work on Google
Chrome I I work on the chrome dev tools
but I've been invested in dev tools and
just generally tooling for a long time I
found this like recently ten years ago I
made this stunner right here a nice
little like cheat sheet of keyboard
shortcuts for our best friend Firebug so
good but you know like even then I was
just really excited to understand what
kind of capabilities tools offered us
because I always like I can I can learn
one more thing and I can be more
productive save my time and save my
stress and we now have some good tools
we have one tool in particular that is
you know our trusty friend go to a
console log we all use it we love it
it's reliable it's everywhere you want
to know what a value is hey console logs
got you back no problem so that's great
but you know you while it is useful like
console log debugging printf debugging
there are more powerful capabilities so
I wanted to touch on a few of those a
year ago at Google i/o the chrome team
introduced some of the work that we've
done to introduce the v8 inspector
component into node bringing some new
debugging capabilities to the node
project we actually announced a pull
request rather than like you know
something shipping but hey you know it
landed and and now it's no it's in there
so that's fine I'm going to quickly walk
through kind of just the basics of how
this works
you have a little hello world script you
can run it like that obviously but you
can run - - inspect how many people have
used - - inspect or something good yes
great ok do this return the debugger
also - just inspect we'll run it turn on
the debugger
and pause it on the very first statement
of the script I find this is really
useful with you know utilities other
things where it's
happen really fast and you want to break
at the very beginning to make sure any
sort of break points are in place now
when you run this you'll get some output
that looks like this hey the debugger is
on it's listening to a WebSocket and
here's some Docs this is a little
different than it was before in previous
node versions you saw something like
this a bit more text and a big long URL
that you felt compelled to like copy
paste and it's kind of awkward anyways
don't do that anymore it's a little bit
better and so this is kind of a good
approach to take so once you turn things
on head over to Chrome a new tab type in
about inspect it'll bring you to a page
that looks a little like this and these
are some inspectable targets you'll see
your the node script mention right here
but click on this guy right here the
dedicated dev tools for node and this is
gonna pop up dev tools it's just for
your node now another approach to do the
exact same thing is if Chrome is open
and then a dev tools windows already
open and then you go and you take your
script and you start inspecting it in
dev tools now and this is a new as of
its shipped to the chrome stable as of
this week right up in the top left
corner will add a nice bright green
shiny nodejs icon click that guy and
that will bring up the dedicated window
for you so just you know the dedicated
window obviously it has less tabs than
your typical chrome dev tools because
we're just dealing with node and its
capabilities but the dedicated window is
great because if you're working with no
if you're working with your application
then you make some changes so your
control seeing the application and then
you rerun it this dedicated window is
going to automatically reconnect to the
node that is now there so it's just
there so it's going to automatically
reconnect whenever there's anyone all
right so those are just kind of the
basics but I want to show a little bit
of how this works in action sooo we have
I'm a little web server app and when I
run it yeah okay yep internal server
error great so we do have some problems
a console is telling me problems great
over in chrome inspect I'm gonna open
this guy up ok so this is the app 40
lines of stuff internal server error is
right here and so one thing that I know
happens it's a little you know it's it's
kind of confused so we're trying to do
this we catch so we got some exception
and then at this point we emit an error
event that actually gets heard up here
when we're listening on this guy and
then this error function is emitting its
own error then passing along the data
now I really want to know what this
exception is right here because I'm not
getting it out on the console but one
thing that I can do is I'm gonna place a
breakpoint well I don't actually want it
here I want to break inside of this
arrow function so I place it this guy
but then turn on this column breakpoint
right here so no all right now we go
over here we reload and I paused inside
of the arrow function and you can see
data is inspectable and so we're paused
inside this guy who's really cool works
phenomenally well with arrow functions
with asynchronous code it's super useful
no I this guy comes down here where I
say problem and I'm losing the details
about this exception somewhere between
there I don't know where exactly I might
start out with like a step in see what
happens but I step in on am it I'm
inside of
you know nodes core events module which
honestly I like I don't want to walk
through this so I'm gonna right click
and I'm gonna black box this guy and
with black box scene it's just saying
hey you probably you know you're just
gonna avoid stepping through this so we
can see now in the Cossack it says that
a few call frames are completely black
boxed and so now when I step in we step
directly to my own event handler for the
exact same thing so just by passing all
out right well we got that under control
and E is telling us well this string we
still don't have our exception open
other consoles just be like it is
arguments yep there it is okay there are
two arguments right okay that string and
then the actual exception so I was just
being silly
so what we can do just take this guy
ctrl D for multiple selection comma and
spread good and I'm gonna hit control s
ctrl s is alive at it's kind of like a
hot module reloading at the v8 level and
so now when i refresh the same guy well
I'm still paused I'm still paused hey
now when i refresh yeah there we go okay
so I was just getting the logs before
and now yes the actual exception made
its way through nice thing here is I
didn't have to like restart node the
live edit meant that I'm able to just
keep that running make some changes and
then see what happens alright so thank
you
so just a few things here column
breakpoints block boxing live at it all
that's good stuff that's been available
when you're debugging Chrome now all
available when you're debugging with
note as well all right bring it back to
these guys so if you've done this before
and you feel like it takes a little bit
of work just to bring up that window
there are some tools that help with this
to make it like a one action thing yeah
I want a bug window as a Chrome
extension called NIMH project called
spec process another one called the
rocket just makes it kind of a single
action to get that up and running really
what they're doing is opening this URL
we just need the dev tools URL with the
WebSocket kind of hooked into it but
because it's a kind of a fancy URL you
can't open it in normal ways so that's
that's kind of under the covers all
right I want to briefly touch on four
kind of other approaches apart from
those basics one situation you might
find yourself in is you ran node
normally no flags
no anything but you've reached a state
and you're now like I really want to
debug it profile I don't know you want
to start inspecting it is it too late
it's not too late no no you can do it
process debug process and pass it just a
process ID is a number you can run this
in a completely different no process and
it'll just flip on debugging and your
target really cool that works if you
want to do toboggan and you're more of a
terminal kind of person and you want
like a gdb style interface you can use
the existing CLI debugger this has been
a node for quite some time but the
backend was recently redone to be
sitting on the new implementation but
you just work with the script here on
the command line with some short
commands it's very great now another
approach is via the dev tools protocol
now as you saw there's this WebSocket
port and that just speaks JSON RPC with
the dev tools protocol this right here
what we're looking at
is a script that attaches to Chrome or
Chrome headless and just capture as a
JavaScript profile just automatically if
we wanted to take this script and have
it run against node instead we just
changed the port to connect to nodes to
bug in port otherwise the rest of it
works the entire dev tools protocol that
chrome uses it's obviously bigger than
the set of what node is using but
there's some great overlap around
profiling debugging console and the
runtime all this so you can do this over
here over the WebSocket another approach
is to use the new core inspector module
that was added I think it's new in eight
and here you just set up a session and
you talk the same exact same protocol
profiler enables start/stop same thing
as we were doing the last one but this
is happening inside of your node process
instead also a decent option with
debugging the other way I want to
quickly touch on tracing because there's
some cool stuff now tracing is a very
powerful collection of tools on the
chrome team we use this to understand
what is happening in the browser this is
two seconds of loading a page on
Wikipedia and on Chrome we use this to
understand what is happening and
anything that's taking time we go to a
trace that is the ground truth and so
much stuff is instrumented there and
this is like the most basic looking
thing it can get a lot more involved but
we're gonna skip over that traces are
really really powerful and the great
thing is now this whole capability is
available in node it is still early days
but this is how you can do it run with
trace events enabled and after you run
this it's going to spit out a JSON file
of the trace and you can open that up in
chrome in a about colon tracing just
drag it in and you'll see something like
this this is one that I captured with
node just the other day so there's a few
things going on here and it gets really
interesting
in this area in the middle not gonna
zoom in and export too much but I've
selected this whole region and down at
the bottom we see some of the results we
have that we know how much time v8 spent
executing compiling parsing doing GC
work total time self time and on CPU
time so some nice break down around the
timings of what's happening on that
thread and then above it is some really
fascinating stuff and this is actually
showing me here kind of a breakdown of
where my latencies are between DNS and
TCP connection and the rest of the
network requests really helps in this
case identify where the the certainly
entities are I will point out that this
aspect is sitting on top of the new
async rap implementation in node core
and this part isn't yet in isn't yet
landed in node there's a good-looking
pull request really good stuff that when
landed will enable this still the the
kind of detail in here in the trace it's
there's a lot more opportunity so I'm
really excited to see continued
investment in instrumentation and
understanding all sorts of things and
what's happening inside node like
understanding when the event loop is
doing work or whatever this is a great
solution to instrumenting all that and
building tools around it yes good a
basic trace looks like that but there
are some off by default categories which
give you more detail at the cost of a
little overhead this would be the
magical incantation that turns on all
those categories yeah there you go so
that's about gonna wrap it up for me one
last thought I want to leave you with is
just explore and think what is beyond
the console
thank you guys very much
[Applause]